[Applause]  15 points philadelphia lead  17 of the 36 coming from embiid  turner close by double comes  there's fiber now he'll go to the hole  leave it that's  all beautiful offense as steival set up  ben  simmons  and now embiid jawed with capella  officials get between them  sixers with all kind of swagger here  tonight  in front of their home crowd  it'll be a technical i believe on embiid  young will knock it down  [Applause]  saw simmons and galinari that embiid  john and capela  and david guthrie hits him with a team  he must have said some magical words  because in the playoffs you know usually  you let you know the emotions are going  to be high  and i will defer that the referees will  allow some of that but he must have said  something off-kilter to that'll force  the official  to call it but i love the intensity  right now i'm seeing from joelle levine  his body language is right